we are just going to go through week by
week
and talk a little bit about each of the
chapters in turn so
two weeks ago it was the introduction
today is chapter one which is called the
human niche
and i'm going to read just two pages
from a section called culture versus
consciousness
and this is a topic to which you know
which we have discussed
here and which we discussed in a talk
that we gave virtually at princeton
a year ago 13 months ago or so and
which we expand on quite a lot in the
penultimate chapter of the book so we'll
be coming back to this
to these topics um in i guess 11 weeks
so culture versus consciousness
consciousness is valuable for problem
solving but it isn't so good for
execution
the gymnast the virtuoso and the warrior
all succeed by taking what they have
discovered consciously and learning to
apply it without explicit deliberation
transformative insights and ideas move
out of the conscious layer into the
parts of us that know how to get things
done
when one is in the zone the conscious
mind is present but it's a spectator who
steers clear so as not to disrupt the
flow
behaviors become habitual and intuitive
in an individual we might call this
skill or craft
in a family or a tribe such habits
become traditions passed efficiently
from one generation to the next
scale this up further then we have
culture homo sapiens therefore oscillate
between two dominant modes
when we face problems for which our
prior understanding is inadequate we
become conscious
how do we feed ourselves in this new
land we plug our minds into a shared
problem-solving space and share what we
know
then we parallel process proposing
hypotheses providing observations
offering challenges
until we arrive at a new answer one that
an individual would rarely reach alone
if the result works well when tested in
the world it gets refined and then
driven into a more automatic less
deliberative layer
this is culture the application of
culture to the circumstances for which
it is adapted is the population level
equivalent
of an individual being in the zone this
model implies a few important things
when times are good people should be
reluctant to challenge ancestral wisdom
their culture in other words they should
be comparatively conservative
when things aren't going well people
should be prone to endure the risks that
come with change
they should be comparatively progressive
liberal if you will
this of course has a lot to say about
the modern world because for various
reasons there is little agreement
present on how well things are going
moments before the titanic hit the
iceberg the ship was a marvelous
testament to human achievement
moments after it was a monument to the
hazard of hubris
too often it is only in retrospect that
the rearrangement of deck chairs appears
absurd
more often than not there is no iceberg
no clear demarcation
of before and after of the moment when
consciousness should become more salient
than culture
the financial collapse of 2008 the
deepwater horizon oil spill and the
fukushima daiichi nuclear disaster are
all symptoms of a civilization level
disorder one that has no name
let's call it the suckers folly the
tendency of concentrated short-term
benefit not only to obscure risk at
long-term cost
but also to drive acceptance even when
the net analysis is negative
these events are evidence that we are
resting on our cultural laurels and
speeding toward disaster
lulled into a false sense of security
and away from collective consciousness
by the opulence of our surroundings the
sooner we recognize this the greater the
chance to divert the ship to a safe
course
a puzzle we will return to in the last
chapter of this book
the answer to our earlier question then
what is the human niche is this
humans don't have a niche not in the
standard sense of the term
we have escaped the paradigm by
mastering a different game we have
discovered how to swap out our software
and replace it as the need arises by
oscillating between culture and
consciousness
the human niche is niche switching
humanity is the master of every trade if
we were machines we would be ones that
are compatible with many software
packages
the inuit hunter knows the arctic but
has few of the skills needed to function
in the kalahari or the amazon
humans can be good at almost anything
given the proper tools and software and
human populations can be good at many
things by virtue of a division of labor
but each individual person will either
have to limit themselves or accept the
costs that come with being a generalist
as our world becomes increasingly
complex though the need for generalists
grows
we need people who know things across
domains and who can make connections
between them
not just biologists and physicists but
biophysicists
people who have switched gears and found
the tools they brought from their prior
vocation serve them well in a new one
we must find ways to encourage the
development of generalists
in this book we argue that a key way to
do this is to encourage a careful
nuanced understanding of what evolution
is what it has made us and how we can
resist
its goals i am so excited to have this
finally in the world it's going to be
very useful and i should just
uh point out that the book itself and
this podcast
are exercises in campfire
hence my reference to it in the tweet
that appointed
my followers here and it is something
that is uh it is very
live for us we participate in campfire
to exchange ideas consciously and figure
out what we should think about things
that none of us have seen before
i would also point out not on that list
of disasters
in there is coveted 19 and now that
jon stewart has finally cracked the case
we can recognize that this
is yet one more uh likely testament to
that same
dynamic so well and as as you wrote
about in your most recent unheard piece
as as well right so we will um if i
remember too we'll we'll link that as
well in the video description
um yeah maybe
maybe that's it except that one of the
other things i want to do whenever we
talk about
the book is just read a little bit from
the index because this index tickles me
deeply we when we received it just
whenever it was three weeks ago or so
we were we were laughing um pleased
at it because it really it really
reveals how diverse
a list of things we talk about in the
book is so starting in the middle of a
middle of a this is only a third of what
is in a in the index
uh we have allocation trade-offs
altruistiality
american dream amniotes amphibians
anisogamy sapphire mining in ankarana
anti-anxiety medications antibiotics
antidepressants
anti-fragility ants apes
appendix arctic turns aristotle
art solomon ash who will come up again
in this episode
asexual reproduction astrology atlantic
spotted dolphins
rachel aviv and obviously ayahuasca
[Music]
um so in my opinion when you read from
the index it should be a little more
crazed a little more wild-eyed do you
want to do it no
i don't actually uh yes this is actually
one of my terrors from childhood was
being forced to read out loud yes i've
never it's never been a
a strong suit for me and yet you're
happy to advise me that i need to be a
bit more crazy oh back to fragility
and apes exactly um so i have a question
for you i mean as long as
uh the index of the book has become a
subject of the podcast i have to know oh
boy
okay let's suppose there was more than
one book and therefore more than one
index
indexes or indices
i feel it's indices yeah i do too and i
think maybe we're wrong
and i don't remember why if so wrong you
say
that somehow doesn't feel right i
honestly don't remember i
i this is this is something that
grammarians of course have an opinion on
and um you know in so far
as there's no pressing need to change
how it is that we're supposed to do it
um simply messing with all of the things
that we've always done
at the same time is obviously another
recipe for disaster so
why not leave those things that do
function even if it's not what you
thought they were
alone already but i honestly actually
don't know which it is in this case
yes so the question is left hanging in
the air
hanging hung like i don't know
that's another weird one you know hanged
versus hung yeah it is
it is